I think we're very close to augment to
reality I think all four of us are gonna
have a piece of content in 36 months 36
months that has us at our created pet in
it I think we're very close to having a
cartoon partner in our lives
let me explain snapchats
kind of studio I think we're very close
to augmented reality I think where we go
with that is the your pet I think we're
all gonna I think I think all four of us
are gonna have a piece of content in 36
months 36 months that has us and our
created pet in it a virtual something so
like I have a meeting today with my team
and I'm gonna create basically a Disney
World of characters that are gonna we're
gonna design and we're gonna show up in
my content because you can like
literally like Sasha the sneaker there's
like a sneaker character and I'm gonna
use him for all my sneaker stuff we
should make Airport Gary right away I
want you to design Sasha the sneaker no
grandma B yet we should like Larry the
librarian to support me on the books see
where I'm going
like we know my world that's what 100%
like a marshmallow like maybe he should
maybe his head should be the five
actually think I like that
and by the way we're gonna make that
we're gonna design them in snapchat
we're gonna use them in daily be like
when I make fun of like Rick and Sally
like naturally like their little heads
gonna pop up and be like you know I
think this is the next big IP space I
think in 36 48 months that's where this
all goes you guys all have your own
Tamagotchi kind of like you know you're
gonna all have your own character I look
I think it's the rim stories is like you
know like more reach now than you know
like real actual reach like your
father's see your snapchat stories more
than your actual I'm aware I know just
from like a branding like everyone like
shout outs like on Instagram you know
like have been less about like be
opposed selling more about just stories
so companies have just been using
stories I'm aware like literally like my
sneaker and was what November yeah
November and the book was a January
right in that 8 weeks I went from me
pissed that people were giving me
shoutouts for a sneaker in the story to
wanting them to give it to me in the
story eight weeks but the number one
thing that I think could change our game
really fast is community management the
cool thing is I think everybody should
do it cuz it's the quickest Lert way to
learn what's actually happening here
it's just like listening is different
than replying think about how much I
believe in community management my
second book was the beg you economy
I don't have to tell you
so how long we're two years and then
went to four bears oh really
you held on you didn't want to be knew
right away I knew within two weeks and
you're like [ __ ] yeah you see we're
hacking away to make it worth your while
for three years yeah if you didn't want
to bounce like we planned around that I
don't think it's as big of a deal as
people think you know it's funny he said
that because also some guys who are in
finance and we all stayed this weekend
and I made a comment about that we were
talking about this exact stuff and
they're like I don't know if that
matters realistically the conversation
with some mornings and a look yeah this
is why I didn't work out but I did what
I'm Kevin and you know I don't think it
matters
yeah I'm gonna make a piece of content
about that okay
I have a quick video rant to make all
right well I'm gonna finish it but
because of this yeah hey guys something
that's been emerging just came out of
great meeting with a young winner and my
company um this is just a random piece
of content I think it's gonna help a lot
of people I think a lot of people are
staying in jobs for one or two years
after they realized the job sucks or is
not for them two or three weeks in and I
think the reason they're doing that is
they're worried that it's gonna look bad
on their resume and I just don't think
that's as real as people think in
today's environment I just don't know
what has to say for me the way I look at
it is number one
if a company looks at your resume when
you submit it and sees that you only
work somewhere for two months and that
eliminates you you probably don't want
to work for that company number two if
you get in the door you can just explain
that you used your self-awareness to
recognize it wasn't a good fit or you
undercover this or that or the other
thing or you sold a bag of goods that
weren't real and it's just the thought
of people in their 20s wasting two years
because they want their resume to not
look awkward to then get another job in
a place that would judge you on that
resume just feels like one big [ __ ]
circle so recommendation of the day
don't overthink it like if the job sucks
bounce it's not gonna really [ __ ] up
your resume in the world that we're
actually living in
the social media thing we want to
easiest come here and just talk to you
let's share what we have going on
uh-huh and just hear your thoughts so
YouTube Facebook Instagram is his
channels blew up immediately because he
had just one across the games people
want to start following him yeah of
course it was was skyrocketing right and
but you were taking all that energy and
putting into the gyms instead of the
brand makes sense 2008 he has 30,000
followers on YouTube we get a few
hundred hits on videos so we're filling
to stay awake you know what's amazing
this will get you very excited I don't
think I was much further along three and
a half years ago when I got serious yeah
like I had my thing I was winning good
things were happening and I think it was
at forty eight thousand subscribers on
YouTube yeah I was at thirty-four
thousand and so we had followers like I
was I was big on Twitter cuz that's
where I come from right but I was head
down and building Vayner into like I got
rebooted d-roc started three years I
guess maybe 41 I mean 28 I got rebooted
somewhere in for like three and a half
four years ago and it happened really
fast
um so it's funny I think I was at a very
you know like a lot of people like I'm
in a very good spot right now yeah but
like three and a half four years ago I
was in a stale spot for personal brand
right you need to start thinking of
yourself as a media company I'm sure you
guys it seems like you know enough about
me to know there's nothing I think I'm
gonna tell you that's maybe not
something you've ever heard before you
need have written audio and video formed
content being put out at scale every
[ __ ] you understand here's the thing
it's a land grab is it as easy to become
a CrossFit celebrity today as it was in
2008 no supply and demand right the
supply and demand of been a bit of
awareness and attention in this device
across the 11 platforms that matter will
never be better than it is right now
right and it's not as good as it was
yesterday right got it
if you look at the personalities that
win we're never in the same spot this
this one this girl jumps that guy this
guy goes down this guy goes up it all
happens based on who's best at the thing
that matters the most of the time right
but here's what I'm saying moments in
time right Instagram podcast you know
LinkedIn I'm very bullish on all this
stuff like you have a podcast you have
to you have to have my life are you
ready in full effect
Toronto I'm coming serious good day got
a lot done very energized Vayner sports
had a big day that feels good
and
[ __ ] vaynermedia man Manor X the
whole Vayner X Empire pure Wow big ups
secret projects for the summer I know
that they watching me trying to figure
me up like what's my life like my
committed to perception is relying on
what you